viene questo rumore possenti berlino sul
telefono che squilla non è il mio
telefono
[Musica]
proposta care questo cavo ok forse ora
non spillerà più secondo punto per
rispondere a questo telefono è pronto ma
che sta facendo unità
[Musica]
no
marino che ne pensi dovrei rispondere di
nuovo sì lo so non è una buona idea vero
ma altrimenti non smetterà più di
suonare pronto chi sei pronto come fai a
saperlo
senti non chiamare più anzi dimmi come
far sparire questo telefono ok no grazie
non voglio partecipare a nessun gioco
lasciami in pace ok italia non deve
scoprirlo scoprire cosa e poi cervello
niente un telefono che ho trovato lo so
che è un telefono lo vedo ma è un
telefono antico l'ho trovato in giardino
un giardino che ci facevo telefono in
giardino foto era solo un giocattolo
non è niente steel ha trovato in
giardino ma ora vado a rimetterle
giardino anzi la bocca come fa a suonare
questo telefono sarà una batteria sarà
un bacio claudio rossi ma che stai
dicendo fammi rispondere no perché no
sarà qualcuno che ha sbagliato numero
anzi guarda ecco fatto avranno sbagliato
numero
sì chi parla come murray fessure o
reggerà nessuno non c'era nessun rumore
che in vedita l'aveva creata da cassano
un giocattolo ma si dai volevo solo
partire lo scherzo vabbè io vado a
mangiare
ciao ci è mancato poco che vitale
scoprisse che ho preso questo telefono
dalla scatola che avevo promesso di non
riaprire mai più però è strano come è
possibile che lui ha risposto al
telefono e non ha sentito nessuna voce
c'è qualcosa di molto strano in questo
telefono devo farlo sparire il prima
possibile pitale ha iniziato a
insospettirsi marino aiutami tu come
faccio a farlo sparire
dimmi
lasciami in pace ok non voglio
partecipare al tuo gioco
dimmi solo come far sparire questo
telefono ok
e se mi rifiuto di partecipare che cosa
succede
[Musica]
o no lo senti anche tu berlino se
qualcuno il pd sopra nuovamente devo per
forza andare a controllare e berlino
forse è meglio non mangiarlo quel
telefono sai può essere pericoloso senti
io devo tornare al piano di sopra che fu
controllare se arrivato qualcuno in
soffitto e vi ricordate l'ultima volta
che siamo andati in soffitta assieme
che cosa abbiamo visto portatemi fortuna
e lasciate un mi piace qua sotto
speriamo che non ci sia niente di troppo
pauroso sopra berlino io vado ok ma tu
rimani qui a sorvegliare il telefono e
mi raccomando non farlo toccare a vitale
grazie merlino ci vediamo dopo se riesco
a tornare intera
ciao ok ragazzi eccoci qua alle scale
che portano nella soffitta e forse ho
cambiato idea
non voglio più salire in soffitta
sicuramente non sarà niente dai andiamo
giusto controllare che che sia tutto a
posto
secondo voi chi ce l'ha sopra a tutti ma
marino non stati sorvegliando il
telefono giu tempo e quaderni
senti io devo controllare chi c'è un
cosa c'é qua sopra che ma tu stai
attento vi sentite anche voi questi
rumori ei sei nessuno
forse solo un berlino berlino sei tu che
stai facendo questo rumore forse per
controllare dentro quella porta vi
ricordate cosa è successo l'ultima volta
però meglio non avvicinarsi li avrei
dovuto prendere qualcosa per difendermi
nel caso spunti fuori qualcosa o
qualcuno e merlino sei ancora qua non lo
sento più marino dove sei
eccoti ei rimani qui a fianco a meno che
eccoci qua siamo di fronte alla porta
dovrei aprirla secondo voi si sente
qualcosa dentro le ho sentite
c'è nessuno
chi è meglio non tirarti capua berlino
sei tu berlino dove sei
sei stato tu berlino berlino forse è
andato ad abitare al piano di sotto
strano però berlino dove sei
berlino telefono ha squillato il
telefono al piano di sotto
ma sembra che sia qua in soffitta
[Musica]
secondo voi è lo stesso telefono che
abbiamo scovato nella scatola in camera
o è un altro telefono beh non vi resta
che rispondere anche a questo telefono
pronto
[Musica]